corona maßnahmen wie lange noch immer
mehr fordern spätestens wenn wohl alle
ein impfangebot bekommen haben sollte
schluss sein
ein interview und seine folgen der
umstrittene cdu bundestagskandidat runs
georg maßen bekommt für seine scharfe
journalisten kritik ärger mit der
eigenen partei und jetzt das
viertelfinale in wimbledon spielt sich
angelique kerber mit einem
abschließenden us in die runde der
letzten acht
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sport ein stück von mir
je mehr menschen gegen korona geimpft
sind desto lauter wird die frage
gestellt ob es nicht langsam lang mit
maske tragen und co
so fordert der chef der kassenärztlichen
bundesvereinigung gassen ab herbst alle
corona maßnahmen aufzugeben
im moment haben laut
robert-koch-institut gut 56 prozent der
bundesbürger mindestens eine spritze
bekommen knapp 39 prozent sind
vollständig geimpft das sind mehr als 32
millionen menschen sollen tatsächlich
alle einschränkungen fallen wenn jeder
geimpft werden kann
nena kurschilgen über eine aufgeladene
debatte mal wie wir bei einem
open-air-festival die musik feiern oder
auch ohne maske im supermarkt einkaufen
die freiheit von früher zurück bekommen
die forderungen werden lauter nämlich
genau dann wenn alle menschen einen
impfangebot erhalten haben
rechnerisch sehe dass auf basis von
zahlen des rks und der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung so aus angenommen 88 prozent
der impf berechtigten würden sich impfen
lassen
dann könnten auf basis von derzeitigen
lieferzusagen und den kapazitäten den
impfzentren und arztpraxen bis zum 12 9
alle impfwilligen zweimal geimpft sein
dann glaube ich kann man und muss man in
der logik dann auch sagen dann brauchen
diese kronach maßnahmen nicht mehr in
der form dann kann jeder individuell für
sich immer noch entscheiden ob er eine
maske tragen will wenn sie irgendwo zu
eng wird oder weil er sich nicht impfen
lassen will
das ist aber dann eine persönliche
entscheidung andere sehen das kritischer
auch alle kinder müssten geimpft und
noch viele skeptiker überzeugt werden
erst dann sollte über lockerungen
nachgedacht werden
ich halte das jetzt für nicht sinnvoll
master nur für geimpfte zurück zu fahren
weil wir damit erstens die
zweiklassengesellschaft wieder ansteuern
zweitens wahrscheinlich eine nicht
kontrollierbaren zustand haben werden
weil wie soll man zum beispiel morgens
im berufsverkehr in der vollen u-bahn
wenn dort alle ohne maske sitzen wer
soll das kontrollieren wer geimpft ist
und wer nicht
auch in der politik wird heftig
diskutiert doch eins ist klar es dürfen
bei geimpften menschen nicht mehr in dem
ausmaß die grundrechte
fängt werden wenn du es geht von dir
keine gefahr mehr für dich selber aus
für andere geht keine gefahr aus und
deshalb hast du natürlich einen größeren
freiheit spielraum als diejenigen
menschen von dem potenziell eine solche
gefahr ausgehen kann
die bundesregierung zurückhaltend muss
man auch noch hinzufügen dass es ja
schon geimpft und genesene mit nachweis
schon jetzt eine ganze reihe von
wirklich erheblichen lockerungen und
erleichterungen gibt freiheit versus
sicherheit für die politik bleibt es ein
ballon sagt die argumente pro und contra
finden sie auch auf zdf heute.de und in
der zdf- heute- app dort haben wir
medizinische und rechtliche aspekte
zusammengefasst
schauen wir auf die korona zahlen die
stagnieren auf niedrigem niveau das
robert koch institut meldet 212 neu
infektionen innerhalb eines tages sieben
weniger als vergangenen montag ein
todesfall kam hinzu
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
liegt wie gestern bei 5 in
großbritannien liegt die inzidenz
mittlerweile bei 214 seit wochen steigen
die infektionszahlen dort wieder an vor
allem wegen der hoch ansteckenden delta
variante trotzdem will die regierung die
verbliebenen corona maßnahmen zum 19
juli aufheben
das hat premierminister johnson eben in
einer pressekonferenz angekündigt
andreas stamm in london ist in
großbritannien in zwei wochen
tatsächlich dann alles aufgehoben keine
masken pflicht keine abstandsregeln
so soll es sein massen events nicht nur
wie bei der europameisterschaft im
fußball oder in wimbledon werden dann
auch wieder ohne ausnahmegenehmigung
möglich sein man wird sich wieder in
nachtclubs begeben dürfen treffen wann
und wo und mit wie vielen man auch immer
will und hier mindestabstand nicht mehr
und auch die masken pflicht wird
zumindest nicht mehr bestraft wenn man
keine trägt es geht sozusagen in das
prinzip eigenverantwortung über das kann
also trotzdem sein dass geschäfte oder
auch öffentliche verkehrsmittel sagen
ihr müsst weiter maske tragen aber es
wird dann wenn man es nicht tut eben
nicht mehr bestraft und das motto ist
leben ja mit dem corona virus leben
lernen und so richtig ganz
hundertprozentig sicher die auch boris
johnson nicht müssen angst vor der
eigenen courage denn erst nächste woche
soll das dann wirklich endgültig
verabschiedet werden vielleicht steigen
die zahlen dann doch noch so sehr dass
man doch etwas und mutiger wird aber es
gibt ja auch reichlich mahnungen gegen
diesen schritt begründet johnson sein
vorgehen
ja wenn ich jetzt waren dann das war
sein hauptargument der sommer steht
bevor diese del-tabelle die da kommt
kann das gesundheitssystem da am besten
abfangen
es wird weiter steigende zahlen geben
man rechnet mit 50.000 neuinfektionen
täglich eben am 19 juli und was man eben
aber auch sieht dass die impfstoffe
wirken dass die zahl der
krankenhauseinweisungen und der
todesfälle massiv nach unten geht aber
auch die werden steigen vielleicht das
gesundheitssystem überlastet die
pandemie ist also noch nicht vorbei aber
man sagt einfach jetzt jetzt ist der
beste zeitpunkt kritiker sehen das
anders denn man setzt vor allem kinder
jugendliche dem aus der 50 prozent
anteil die noch nicht doppelt geimpft
sind longo witt ist eine große frage und
vor allen dingen ist das natürlich auch
ein brauhaus für neue varianten dafür
waren die kritiker es ist also ein spiel
mit großem risiko dass boris johnson
hier geht und man wird erst in wochen
sehen wie das ganze dann ausgeht ob das
ein kluger schritt war oder ein weiterer
zurück in einer viel viel schlechtere
zeit dankeschön für diese einschätzung
live aus london andreas stamm baders
in spanien hatte sich die korona lage
auch entspannt aktuell aber steigen die
zahlen wieder stark an vor allem bei
jungen leuten und das in der
hauptreisezeit in der die
tourismusindustrie auf millionen
urlauber hofft die bundesregierung hat
reagiert und jetzt auch katalonien als
risikogebiet eingestuft hier stieg die
sieben tage inzidenz auf über 200 und
auch auf den balearen gibt es wieder
mehr neuinfektionen christel hass das
risiko fliegt mit nach mallorca vor
allem wenn man nicht vollständig geimpft
ist
denn die infektionszahlen dort sind
sprunghaft gestiegen am strand ein
bisschen abstand wenig maske die
besorgnis hält sich in grenzen
ein bisschen abstand halten und auch
maske tragen um einen sicheren urlaub
hat zu gewährleisten wenn wir von tisch
zu tisch gehen oder halt so im klo
musste man halt immer maske tragen
es wurde auch relativ gut eingehalten
nur halt jetzt bergkönig und sowas da
ist es halt
manche halten es nicht ein erst vor
einer woche steckten sich etwa tausend
spanische abiturienten beim feiern auf
der insel an
die große sorge der behörden dass sich
das auf den partymeilen wiederholen
könnte strengere regeln soll es vorerst
nicht geben
der tourismus ist das rückgrat der insel
wir haben alle gelitten auf sozialer
gesundheitlicher und wirtschaftlicher
ebene
wir bitten sie alle um größtmögliche
eigenverantwortung auch auf dem
spanischen festland ist das virus wieder
aktiv katalonien gilt jetzt als
risikogebiet in barcelona sehen die
nächte oft so aus feiern zu hunderten
auf der straße
wenn wir merken dass zu viele menschen
da sind oder keinen abstand eingehalten
wird dann gehen wir
oder setzen unsere mussten auf masken
allerdings trägt kaum einer
es sind vor allem die unter 30 jährigen
die sich infizieren auswirkungen auf die
krankenhäuser hat das noch nicht der
sommer in spanien zwischen hoffen und
bangen
tun sie es jetzt für sich ihre lieben
ihr umfeld und für das ganze land us
präsident biden hat eindringlich an
seine landsleute appelliert sich gegen
korona impfen zu lassen
zum unabhängigkeitstag betonte er die
usa seien in der pandemie auf einem
guten weg aber noch nicht über den berg
auch in nordamerika macht sich die macht
die bilder variante des virus sorgen
besonders in den südstaaten zögern
dennoch viele menschen die impfquote ist
niedrig hans-georg maßen bringt die cdu
mitten im wahlkampf in die bredouille
der ehemalige präsident des
verfassungsschutzes und jetzige cdu
bundestagskandidat hatte dem öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk
meinungsmanipulation vorgeworfen und
einen gesinnungstest für
nachrichtenredakteure gefordert die
opposition wertet das als angriff auf
die pressefreiheit und die cdu versucht
sich in schadensbegrenzung
patrizia wiedemeier und wieder mal ist
dass hans georg maßen der für unruhe in
der union sorgt doch parteichef laschet
äußert sich nicht vor den kameras und
andere aus der parteiführung versuchen
das problem herunterzuspielen sollte es
nicht überbewerten und die äußerungen
würden alles andere als klug alle maßen
ist jemand der ganz ganz weit rechts von
der cdu steht aber bislang war alles das
was er gemacht hat sicherlich so dass es
noch so eben im cdu spektrum passt ex
bundesverfassungsschutz präsident maßen
hat der ndr journalistin verbindungen
zur linksextremen szene vorgeworfen
regte an dass bei der biografie von
einigen redakteuren mal auf den
prüfstand gestellt wird ob diese leute
die charakterliche eigenschaft haben
für die opposition und die spd ist dies
ein inakzeptabler angriff auf die
pressefreiheit
herr laschet schweigt das kann zweierlei
bedeuten entweder mit der
kanzlerkandidat einer derart
gravierenden verletzungen demokratischer
grundregeln eine so geringe bedeutung
bei oder die andere alternative herr
laschet will am rechten rand stimmen
fischen
es zeigt wieder einmal dass herr laschet
der kompass im umgang mit herrn maßen
fehlt die union muss klarstellen dass
sie hans-georg maßen in dem wahlkampf
nicht unterstützte die cdu kann nicht
einfach so tun als ob dass da irgend
einer ist er es immerhin als
bundestagskandidat aufgestellt und das
ist ein problem
ein parteiausschlussverfahren wie von
einigen cdu abgeordneten gefordert sei
heute jedoch kein thema gewesen
beschwichtigungsversuche wir brauchen
unabhängigen journalismus in deutschland
das passiert durch private anbieter aber
natürlich auch durch den öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk das ist ganz
essentiell für die funktionalität einer
demokratie und diese meinung ist die
eindeutige meinung ohne ausnahme auch
der führungsgremien der cdu hans georg
maßen er könnte für die union im
bundestagswahlkampf zum echten problem
werden
theo koll in berlin warum schreibt der
cdu-chef laschet nicht deutlicher ein
nun vielleicht auch weil aus einem
einschreiten aus einem machtwort schnell
eine machtprobe werden kann
eine die man dann auch verlieren kann
wie das thüringer scheitern von ak von
davids vorgängerin ja belegt hat auch
das dürfte die begeisterung für ein
hartes einschreiten begrenzen der cdu
vorsitzende selbst nennt einen formalen
grund über die kandidaten werde vor ort
entschieden und hans-georg maßen ist in
südthüringen mit 86 prozent aufgestellt
worden
aber ich glaube die wesentlichen gründe
dürften politisch strategische sein
laschet hat versprochen alle strömungen
der partei zu integrieren und maßen ist
für einige am see rechten rand der cdu
offensichtlich ein politisch attraktives
angebot und vielleicht ja auch ein
symbol um afd wähler zurückzugewinnen
für armin laschet bleibt maßen ein
problem und ein dilemma
danke theo koll nach berlin mit dem
ungarischen ministerpräsidenten viktor
orban steht erstmals ein regierungschef
eines eu-landes bei reporter ohne
grenzen auf deren liste der größten
feinde der pressefreiheit
seit seiner wahl greife orban
pluralismus und die unabhängigkeit der
medien an teilte die
journalistenorganisation mit aktuell
umfasst die liste 37 staats und
regierungschefs und chefinnen darunter
brasiliens präsident bei zur nato und
die regierungschefin von konko will
jetzt in den heißen sommermonaten wagen
besonders viele migranten den weg über
das mittelmeer nach europa meist in
überfüllten kaum seetauglichen booten
seit anfang januar sind dabei laut
vereinten nationen mehr als 800 menschen
ertrunken
experten gehen von weit höheren zahlen
aus in den vergangenen tagen konnte das
private rettungschef ocean waking 572
menschen aus seenot retten andreas post
berichtet dicht gedrängt auf einem boot
mitten in der nacht auf hoher see heute
morgen stellt sos méditerranée dieser
fotos ins netz und teilt mit in einer
fünfstündigen rettungsaktion habe man
369 menschen an bord der ocean viking
genommen darunter 110 unbegleitete
minderjährige völlig überfüllt dass
große holzboot vor der libyschen küste
in seenot erklärt die hilfsorganisation
danach per videotelefon
binnen weniger tage hatte die ocean
viking mehr als 570 menschen an bord
genommen den angaben zufolge aus eritrea
ägypten bangladesch und dem sie zudem
auf dem weg nach europa über das
mittelmeer zwischen libyen tunesien und
malta immer wieder erheben in joe's
dabei schwere vorwürfe gegen die
libysche küstenwache
diese aufnahmen von swatch dokumentiert
abgefeuerte warnschüsse um ein boot an
der weiterfahrt zu hindern
außerdem zerstört die küstenwache lehre
boote um sie unbrauchbar zu machen jedes
dieser boote ist ein ausrufezeichen
richtung europa hält migranten aber
nicht ab von der gefährlichen passage
die ocean viking sucht jetzt einen
sicheren hafen
elf tage nach dem gebäudeeinsturz nahe
miami sahen die behörden eine neue
gefahr am horizont und zogen trotz der
andauernden bergungsarbeiten die
reißleine
die noch stehenden reste des wohnhauses
wurden kontrolliert gesprengt weil sich
ein tropensturm der küste floridas
nähert wird und regen hätten die
einsatzkräfte sonst massiv gefährdet
hieß es
bislang wurden 27 tote geborgen knapp
120 menschen werden noch vermisst
er liebte den jazz aber berühmt machten
ihn seine schlager bill ramsey ist im
alter von 90 jahren gestorben
minute egal und souvenirs mit seinen
ohrwürmern eroberte ramsey die hitparade
der ehemalige ge lieferte den sound zum
wirtschaftswunder
später wandte er sich wieder mehr dem
jazz zu und stand als sänger bis ins
hohe alter auf der bühne
die mini aber ließ ihn nicht mehr los
[Musik]
immer wieder schön wie auch die
fußball-em morgen das erste der beiden
halbfinals im londoner wembley stadion
erstmals vor 60.000 zuschauern und das
trotz steigender corona zahlen die
spanier die taten sich zuletzt schwer
gegen die schweiz die italiener dagegen
mit bislang mitreißenden souveränen
turnierauftritt
nicht weit von florenz ist die
renaissance des italienischen fußballs
entstanden nach 15 jahren ohne titel
wurden hier im trainingszentrum der
blauen tor kunstwerke entworfen wie
zuletzt gegen belgien in dem stil soll
es gegen spanien weiter gehen ich
erwarte ein technisch anspruchsvolles
spiel von beiden seiten ein schönes
spiel gute spieler auf dem platz und
wird immer schön die spanischen
gegenspieler gehen davon aus ihren
schwachen turnierstart komplett
überwunden zu haben
ich sehe enorme freude und
selbstvertrauen weil alle überzeugt sind
das halbfinale verdient erreicht zu
haben
seit 2008 treffen sie bei jeder em auf
italien 2012 hat spanien das finale
gewonnen
deutschlands beste tennisspielerin
angelique kerber setzt ihre
beeindruckende sieges-serie wimmelten
fort und hat das viertelfinale erreicht
die turniersiegerin von 2018 bezwang die
us amerikanerin kari golf mit 6 4 6 4
jetzt ist dir alles zuzutrauen angelique
kerber ist auf gras fast schon wieder so
stark wie bei ihrem wimbledon-sieg 2018
die große amerikanische tennis hoffnung
konnte ihr noch nicht standhalten
die 33 jährige deutsche war gegen ihre
16 jahre jüngere rivalin ihre besten
tugenden in die waagschale
insbesondere ihren kampfgeist nach 76
minuten matchball kerber zum 6 zu 4 und
6 zu 4
dass sie bereits morgen zum
viertelfinale gegen die tschechin mutter
war antreten muss kommt ihr gerade recht
ich genieße meine zeit hier es ist
einfach großartig vor ihnen zu spielen
das gibt mir die energie mein bestes
tennis zu spielen
ihre freude springt einfach über wenn
auch heute nicht unbedingt auf ihre
gegnerin die deutschen basketballer
reisen erstmals seit 2008 wieder zu
olympischen spielen nach dem sieg
gestern abend im finale des
qualifikationsturniers in split bester
deutscher werfer gegen starke
brasilianer moritzberg mehr mit 28
punkten 75 zu 64 der endstand und das
ticket für tokio inklusive das was uns
gott so glückliche menschen nicht schön
zum schluss noch der blick auf royale
gäste in berlin
der niederländische könig willem
alexander bewies sein können als pilot
er flog seine frau maxima in die
deutsche hauptstadt zum ersten
offiziellen staatsbesuch der beiden
da ging es erst ins schloss bellevue zum
bundespräsidenten dann ans brandenburger
tor morgen steht ein treffen mit der
kanzlerin an
das wetter spielt dabei mich wirklich
mit auch morgen gibt's unwetter mit
hagel und starkregen mehr dazu gleich
von ist in terni marietta slomka freut
sich auf sie im heute journal um viertel
vor zehn
wir freuen uns wenn sie morgen wieder
dabei sind danke für ihr interesse an
schönen abend noch und auf wiedersehen